(audience cheering)
- Today is a very special hour
as we celebrate the final season of one
of the most fun and clever
shows of the last decade,
"The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel."
(audience cheering)
Exactly.
Everyone involved has won
numerous awards for their work
on the show 'cause it's an excellent show.
You can see the fifth and final season
on Prime Video with new episodes weekly.
From "The Marvelous Mrs.
Maisel" please welcome
Rachel Brosnahan,
(audience cheering)
Alex Borstein, Tony Shalhoub, Michael Zegen.
(cheerful upbeat music begins)
(audience cheering)
(cheerful upbeat music continues)
What's up, y'all? Get it
out, get it out. (laughs)
(audience cheering)
We're so excited to have you here.
It's the fifth and final,
I've had you here before.
Welcome to the show, everybody.
- I think I was here virtually,
no, we were on the roof.
- We were on the roof. We roof party.
(Rachel laughing)
So did did any of you know
each other before this show?
- We did.
- I saw Tony in a lot of movies.
(audience laughing)
- I knew Alex a little bit.
- [Alex] We met on Mad TV.
- Right.
- We met on Mad TV.
- They asked me do an episode of Mad TV,
I was a massive fan of that show.
- And I was a massive fan of his
and I had a little secret crush on him.
(Kelly awwing)
- Wasn't that big a secret.
She would hang out backstage.
(audience laughing)
- I'm not subtle.
- [Kelly] Subtle. (laughing)
- Yeah, so we met way back when.
And he looks exactly the
same, which is not fair.
(overlapping chatter)
- Yeah, you do have that thing,
the fountain of the same thing, the youth.
You look the same.
- Fountain of cosmetic surgery?
- No, no, no, no, no.
(audience laughing)
Well, I have to--
- Benjamin Button over here.
- Yeah, aging backwards
- Also, we knew each other before.
Michael and I met when I was 19.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- It's not as salacious as you think.
(audience laughing)
- When we were teenagers...
- Well we did a reading,
we did a play reading.
And I remember walking
you back to the subway
'cause you were going back to NYU.
- You walked me to the
subway? That's so nice.
- She remembered it too.
- Which I also remember.
(Alex laughing)
- That's so nice. That is nice.
So I have to ask, what was
the last day on set like?
Because that's a big deal.
- Yeah, it was awful, it was awful.
- [Rachel] It was terrible. (laughs)
- A lot of tears.
- It was painful. I mean, we
just all love the show so much.
We love the work and we just
couldn't quite wrap our brains
around the fact that it was,
you know, coming to a close.
- I feel like sometimes it
doesn't hit you till afterwards.
- Yeah, we had been, I mean,
Alex is a picture of stoicism
most days on set. (laughs)
- Yeah, I'm usually very
cold and, well, kind of mean.
(Kelly laughing)
- I saw the other word
flash through your eyes.
- She kept it daytime.
- For Kelly Clarkson, it's
daytime, it's daytime.
(Kelly laughing)
- Don't worry, they have
to bleep me all the time.
You're fine.
- But we had to rehearse
one of our scenes early
that morning on the
last day, and we came in
and sort of stood across from each other
and we were starting to rehearse
and Alex was getting teary
at like eight o'clock in the morning.
- I couldn't look at
her. I just looked away.
- Could not look me in the eyes.
And then I couldn't look her in the eyes.
And so we spent all of our
rehearsals kind of looking,
I was thinking, I was
looking at the center
of your forehead and you
were looking at my...
(audience laughing)
- To be fair, isn't that usually
where you have to look at me?
You're right.
(audience laughing)
- So Michael, did you get to
keep this super creepy doll?
I wanna show everyone this doll.
(Michael laughing)
- [Rachel] Our daughter.
That's our daughter, Kelly.
- I have adopted that super creepy doll.
She lives with me now.
(Kelly laughing)
No, no, no, no. No, I left her behind.
Very creepy, sticky doll.
- It would've just been
fun if you took it, though,
and then you kept it,
like, in your guest bedroom
for when people came over,
just randomly in a corner.
- It'd be nice to have a guest bedroom,
but I live in New York.
(audience laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
- [Alex] Nice flex, Kelly.
- I'm so sorry. (laughs)
Oh, I just, you know why I went there is
I stayed at, that's gonna
sound like a flex too,
I stayed at someone's house.
- [Alex] Who's house, Kelly?
- No, and they had a doll.
- Out with it, Kelly.
- It was Reba and I stayed at her house.
(audience laughing)
She had a doll though,
it was just this doll.
And it was so creepy to me.
Just, dolls are creepy to me.
And it was maybe a family
thing, I don't know what it was.
But then like two days later, she's like,
"So we found the doll in the closet"
and I'm like, "Oh my God, I'm
sorry I didn't put it back."
(audience laughing)
It scared me and I couldn't sleep.
I was just like, "I'm not gonna sleep
with that thing looking at me."
(audience laughing)
- I've done that at Airbnbs.
I've had that happen at Airbnbs.
They had something very
creepy and I can't look at it.
- She was like, "Did you
put my stuff in the closet?"
I was like, "I kind of did."
(audience laughing)
I did, I did, I'm so sorry.
I should have brought it back out. Anyway.
- I took some ties, you know.
- [Kelly] See? Klepto, I like it.
(audience laughing)
- Some of Joel's ties, they're
vintage ties and really cool.
So I took about 20 of them.
(audience laughing)
- I mean, speaking of
that though, the vintage--
- I know, I'm sorry.
I hope Donna the costume
designer's not watching.
But yes, I have them.
(Kelly laughing)
- Speaking of costume design,
it's incredible, this show.
That's why, the acting is so impeccable.
The writing is great. The storytelling.
The wardrobe, the art
department that makes all those,
you just really feel like
you're there in time.
Speaking of costume design, it's so cool.
Like, it's such a great team you're in.
That's why I know you're crying at 8 a.m.
'Cause it's, it's a great team
and that doesn't always
happen, like, you know?
- It doesn't. It was a rare, rare thing.
(audience applauding)
- So going back to the
beginning of, well, everything.
Tony, one of your many sisters
got you into acting, right?
- Right.
One of my older sisters was in high school
and they were doing a musical,
they were doing "King and I,"
and I was recruited.
They asked, I guess for them all to bring
their younger siblings
to play the children.
And I wasn't exactly asked,
but I was kind of recruited.
There were handcuffs.
- Oh my God, I thought
you were gonna be like,
"I just kinda walked up there."
(audience laughing)
- No, no.
I was recruited, and
yeah, that was kind of
my first exposure to the stage.
- That's exciting. Because
you didn't know it was coming.
That fresh feeling.
- I was six years old.
(Kelly awwing)
- Rachel, how did your parents feel
when you told them that you wanted to act?
- They were horrified.
Supremely disappointed.
(Kelly laughing)
No, I think they were holding out hope
until probably about five
minutes ago that maybe
I was gonna become a
lawyer or something useful
and contribute to society in some way.
No, they were, I think they
just, they were nervous.
You know, it's an impossible job.
- It's a hard one at that.
- We don't this because you're
well adjusted and normal
and it's a really difficult
thing to have success at.
- Yeah, but Alex, you started in standup.
And when was the first
time you got up on stage
and kind of got that bug?
- I know, it's a little, I don't know
if you can actually call
it standup, but I was 16
and I did stand up at this bar. (laughs)
At a bar that was willing to put me up.
And so my parents had to come
'cause I wasn't old enough
to even be in the bar.
(audience laughing)
And they paid me $20 in cash.
And I can tell you--
- $20 in cash. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
- I've only been paid,
that's only the second time
in my life I was ever paid to do standup.
(Kelly laughing)
Like, I'm not joking.
Like, from then on, I did
that little gig, and then
every other thing I did was free open,
open mic, open mic, open
mic, no one paying, you know.
And it was a very good
lesson to learn very early.
But you kept that $20 bill.
- I do still have it.
- [Kelly] You do?
- Yeah. It's in a little frame.
- [Kelly] That is so cool!
(audience cheering)
- I kept it.
- I love that.
So now you've got a new standup
special coming out, right?
- I do, I do. It's a comedy special.
Maybe we should call it,
like, a filthy TED talk.
(audience laughing)
- That is the best teaser.
(laughs) That's great.
- It's kind of a filthy,
there's lessons to be learned.
There's storytelling, there's
music, there's singing.
It's a deeply personal, wildly fictitious,
filthy account of my life.
(audience laughing and cheering)
- Don't you wanna watch it now?
- It's amazing. We saw it
live, it's so, so good.
- It's on Amazon Prime, shock, surprise.
(audience cheering)
- [Michael] You shot it in the Wolford,
which was the burlesque theater
that we used on our set.
- Yeah, before they tore it down I begged
and I was like, "Can I use it?"
And Amy was like, "Of course."
So it's kind of special.
Like, nothing else has ever
been shot there aside from--
- That's not kind of special.
That's really rad, yeah.
So wait, so Michael, do you
remember your first performance?
- I mean, I wanted to be an actor
since I was, like, five years old.
But I mean, so there were a few firsts.
I wrote my fifth grade play.
- What?
- Yeah, I wrote my fifth
grade play. It was--
- [Kelly] Ahead of your time. (laughs)
- It was a play about
aliens coming down to earth
and these kids teaching them
about the Bill of Rights.
(audience laughing)
- Trying to make it interesting.
Make history awesome.
- It didn't go very well, to be honest.
A kid forgot a line and there
was a five minute pause.
(audience awwing)
- [Kelly] Oh my god, this is adorable!
(audience applauding)
- [Michael] That's a different play.
That was a different one.
- [Rachel] Very serious actor, Michael.
- [Michael] That's me in
high school, by the way.
- I know, oh my God.
I love that you tell this
kind of story. (laughs)
(audience awwing)
- [Michael] That was "Cats".
I was Rum Tum Tugger.
- Oh my God, I love you!
(audience laughing)
I do love when everybody,
everybody always thinks,
you know, they've made
it right off the bat.
Nobody sees that groundwork
and the hustle to pay bills
while you're trying to get your dream.
So did any of you have any
random jobs before this?
Like, what did you do before acting?
- I definitely did.
- I did, yeah.
- What was yours?
- I worked as, you know, dishwashers,
bus boys, waiters many times.
But the coolest job I had was,
I worked on a garbage truck.
- You did?
- Yeah, it was like a
privately owned company,
not a municipal company.
(Kelly laughing)
It was like a resort area.
- [Kelly] It was fancy garbage. I like it.
- It was fancy.
(audience laughing)
It was the best job.
- I like it.
(Rachel laughing)
- Because you're not stuck inside.
- That's true. You're not.
- And we like wear like
these funky bib overalls
and hang on the back of the truck.
- How long did you do that?
(Kelly laughing)
- It was a summer job.
- I'm gonna be honest with you,
one of my things that
I did when I was a kid
to help my stepdad out was we
would always go to the dump
to like, take stuff, I loved it.
It was like treasure. I
mean, you know, it was fun.
- I got a lot of cool
things on my route, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Exactly.
You're like, "That couch
isn't that bad." (laughs)
It's in your living room in a minute.
Okay, so what other jobs did y'all have?
- I worked, well, way back
when I did telemarketing,
I apologized to everyone.
(audience laughing)
- [Rachel] I have telemarketed as well.
- [Kelly] You did?
- I did telemarketing.
And it was to sell photos,
like, family portraits.
And at one point, and I'd
sold none, I'd sold none.
We were locked in a dark
room, there were no windows.
I think people were even allowed to smoke,
like, in the closed room,
this is how old I am.
And at one point the
manager was kind of like,
"The person who sells next
is gonna get 100% bonus"
or something so I called my parents.
(audience laughing)
- That's just smart, that's smart.
- And I sold them a portrait.
And I still have that
photo of my mother and I
and it's the worst thing you've ever seen.
(Kelly laughing)
Ever. I have like a big
perm and acrylic nails
with, I think, like,
airbrushed dragons on them.
(Rachel laughing)
- You just described what I looked like
in my glamour shot when I was, like, 16.
- That's basically what it was.
- You've really been holding out on us.
We've gotta see this photo. (laughs)
- That was a good one.
I will send it to you.
(Rachel laughing)
- [Kelly] You're welcome in advance.
- I worked at a theme restaurant
called Jekyll and Hyde in New York.
And the owner or the manager
came up to me and he had, like,
a stack of menus and
he was, like, you know,
it wasn't busy that day and he was like,
"Take these menus and
wash them." And I left.
(audience laughing)
- You walked out?
- I was like, "This isn't my job."
And I hated it in any way and I left.
And I never got a call from them.
Nobody tried finding out where I was.
(audience laughing)
If I was okay.
- You could have a Dateline
special. Nobody cares.
- They hated you as
much as you hated them.
- I think the turnover at
Jekyll and Hyde was pretty high.
- It might have been
their way of firing you.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Let's see
what he'll do. (laughs)
- I was due.
- "Don't you know who I am?
I'm Michael. I taught the
aliens the Bill of Rights."
(audience laughing)
- "You must have missed my
play in fifth grade." (laughs)
Would've been amazing. (laughs)
(audience applauding)
So let's talk about what
happens in the final season.
Michael, I'm gonna start with you.
Like, where's your character at?
- You know, this season
we do some flash forwards
instead of flashbacks
and so I think people
are gonna be surprised
to see where Joel is.
That's all I can really say.
- Okay, okay.
(Michael laughing)
I like that tease. All
right, what about you, Tony?
What about your character?
- Yeah, I guess the biggest
shift for my character is,
you know, when the show started out,
Abe was this sort of, like,
a man of his time where,
you know, his grandchildren
were kind of, like,
children are to be seen and not heard
and he was kind of dismissive of them.
But by the middle or end of
season five, he's really,
his main focus, really,
is on these grandchildren.
So I thought that was kind of
an interesting arc for him.
- Not too dissimilar to your real life.
- And I was gonna say.
- And in my real life.
- Because he has the most
beautiful grandchildren
I have ever seen, ever.
(audience awwing)
- And also it's worth mentioning
I'm like one of the youngest grandfathers.
(audience laughing)
- And also it's worth
mentioning I'm a zaddy.
(audience laughing)
That's amazing. (laughs)
All right, Alex, how about
you? Where's your character at?
- You know, my favorite
thing about Susie is that
she kind of started like a
balled up armadillo, you know?
(Kelly laughing)
And every season she just kind of has,
Amy's, like, cracked it open
a little bit unwillingly.
You learn more and the vulnerability
just kind of spills out
and she doesn't necessarily go up,
you know, on a trajectory.
She kind of opens and it comes out.
She goes in and it's fascinating to me.
- [Kelly] Get to see the layers.
- Gets vulnerable and the layers open.
- Is it kind of fun 'cause
it's challenging though?
- Yeah.
- You're having to show
different sides of your character
that we maybe haven't seen before?
- Absolutely. Yeah.
- So Rachel, where's your character at?
- So, I mean, I feel like this
season shows Midge and Susie,
this is their make it or break it year.
They have hit rock bottom,
they've gone back and forth.
They've taken 10 steps
forward and 25 steps back.
And Midge has also been
humbled enough at this point
as someone who had experienced
very few instances of humbling
when we met her in the pilot.
To realize that maybe she's
been taking Susie for granted,
she's been taking their partnership
for granted in some ways
and she owes it to herself
and to the people around her
that she's put through this
incredible and crazy journey
alongside her to buckle down
and get her done, as they say.
And so I think she puts that faith
really permanently and
forcefully in Susie.
And the two of them kinda link arms
and figure out how
they're gonna get there.
And the route is, as you
can expect, not so linear.
A little bit surprising.
- That's what makes it interesting.
- There's some shenanigans along the way.
We ice skate. There's
Maisel on ice skates.
- [Kelly] You ice skate?
- We ice skate this season.
- Wait, have you ever done that?
Are you one of those
actors that tells everybody
you can do it and you get
there and you're like, "huh?"
- Yes, absolutely yes.
(audience laughing)
- No, that's real.
(Alex laughing)
That's real. I could not do that.
- Alex is really ice skating.
Shock of everyone's lives.
- You were an ice skater.
- I was a childhood ice
skater for about five minutes.
- With that tone. "I was
a childhood prodigy."
- I was not.
I got a ice call from Amy
during like our break.
(audience laughing)
- It's the pose for me.
That's how you know I was
serious and professional.
- [Kelly] It's the visor for me. (laughs)
- Oh my God, that's amazing.
- It's like riding a bike, kinda.
You've done it a couple
times, it starts to come back.
I didn't break my face and
so I count that as success.
- That's a win.
- But Amy's famous for this.
She sends these texts to us once a year.
She'll go, I think Marin got one saying,
"Do you speak French?"
And Marin was like, "Mhmm."
(audience laughing)
I got one saying, "Can
you play ping pong?"
I was like, "Like a pro."
(audience laughing)
- I will in a month.
- What did you get?
- [Kelly] Just so it
turns out I'm a champion.
- "Can you bowl?"
- Mine was bowling.
- "Can you ride a bike?"
I got at some point.
- It was great.
- Did you have to learn how?
- I mean, I had always bowled, you know,
at birthday parties and whatnot.
(Rachel laughing)
Not a professional, but I did,
a friend of mine is
really good at bowling,
so he gave me a lesson and it worked.
I mean, you know, proper form.
And it was in those Catskill scenes.
In the script it says Joel bowls a strike.
- No, you didn't do it. Oh, come on.
(Michael laughing)
God.
- I didn't do it.
Because the lane was
warped. It was an old--
- Obviously.
(audience laughing)
- It was the lane. (laughs)
- So later on when I
watched the scene back
I was like, "Oh, did I do that?"
And you know, they told me
no, it was special effects.
(Kelly laughing)
- "Am I that amazing?" "No,
we're amazing editors." (laughs)
So overall, what are y'all
most proud of with this show?
I'll start with you, Rachel.
- Oh man. Most proud of?
That we made it. (laughs)
- You more than made it.
Y'all connected with so many people.
Everybody loves the show.
- I think it's that, I've said
it a lot, but we've all been
a part of shows that we're
really proud to be a part of
that just never find the audience.
It's a lot of hard work and
a little bit of stardust
and we're so proud to
have been a part of it
and that it found its
people and that it reached
so many different people
for different reasons.
It's been so amazing over
the last five, six years
to meet, especially
young women who have said
that they felt inspired by
this character to take a risk
in their own lives, to try
stand up for the first time.
To be braver and more
confident. It's just beautiful.
- You're giving hope to people's dreams,
like, that maybe they
put on the back burner.
- And to make them laugh.
I'm proud of so many things.
- Yeah. What are y'all proud
of being part of this show?
- I think I'm most proud
of the fact that, you know,
this cast, this ensemble, you
know, over the course of five,
six years, really,
really just stayed tight,
stayed respectful, checked
their egos at the door.
It was literally virtually conflict free
which just doesn't
always happen, you know?
Something's going on
or something's going on in someone's life
and then that enters into the workspace.
But with this group, it was just a joy.
I think we all should be, you
know, really proud of that.
- Yeah. And not take it for granted.
I know y'all have been on other jobs,
so you know that isn't always true.
So it's nice when you work,
even, like, when I do, like,
"The Voice" and the, the coaches, like,
you have like such camaraderie with them
and so you gotta, like, appreciate
it in the moment and go,
"Ooh, it's not always like this.
Like, have such a good
time and be present, yeah.